he's Super Bowl champion quarterback for
the New England Patriots he Stephon
Gilmore he's joining the Rich Eisen show
and and Stephan has it sunk in yet just
to hear your name sir Bowl champions to
find Gilmour again I think you're really
sucking yesterday at the parade you know
this in all the fans and celebrating in
the brain that was Super Bowl champs
tell me about the parade though because
last year 2017 season you sign in free
agency to New England a heartbreak in
terms of losing the Super Bowl did not
have that parade then all of us this
year you win and you're a part of that
parade so describe the feeling kind of
throughout the parade yesterday know the
great feeling you know just seeing all
the fans you know everyone happy in you
know like you said I didn't experience
that last year came up a little short
but this year was a great feeling um you
know there's a lot of fans there it was
more than what I was another cry
probably two months or three miles and
see a couple fans but I never seen that
many people in my life at one time and
it was it was a great feeling
what was the weather like because some
guys decided to take their shirts off I
know you're a more reserved guy you kept
your shirt off so when you see guys with
their shirt off wait just describe just
a feeling amongst the players you guys
on those floats and and just
accomplishing something that you know a
lot of people throughout the season said
they can't do it this season yeah well
actually it wasn't that cold it was
probably 55 degrees I mean it wasn't
Boston where the whales it wasn't as
cold as it should be but it was a great
feeling all the hard work we put in
during the season they're in all season
you know in accomplishing that one goal
and that's the win the Super Bowl uh you
know what we've been through alluded to
a lot adversity and we overcame it and
can't believe in each other Super Bowl
champion he's Super Bowl champion
cornerback of the New England Patriots
to fajn Gilmore and on Twitter at
bump-and-run Gilmore and
I remember 2012 we were both teammates
in Buffalo with the Buffalo Bills and
here's this kid they drafted in the
first round from South Carolina and he's
wearing number 27 first of all that
number 27 used to look so stanky on you
by the way I wanted 24 with paraplegia
switch over to number 24 and you think
about your years in Buffalo and then
free agency comes you go to obviously
the New England Patriots when you think
about your football career so far and
you only just finished seven seasons
kind of describe you know the feeling
from going from where you're at in
Buffalo just try to contend and never
got to the playoffs to in two straight
years now getting to the Super Bowl and
then finally winning one you know you
just never know how those things go free
agency and stuff like that but you know
Buffalo got drafted there they gave me a
great opportunity and you know I loved
it there my years but we just didn't you
know accomplish much there but I was
able to you know play for my teammates
and you know how to opportunities a beer
know England Patriot and you know they
brizola
you know two Super Bowls back-to-back
and you know contribute as much as I can
you know you just never know how it's
gonna go but I'm happy that I'm in New
England now and they gave me the
opportunity to come here but when you
well when I talked to you all week it
seemed like there was a calm about you
last week during Super Bowl week that
you guys just felt like the Rams and I
know they came in scoring 30-plus points
a game but it just seemed like you guys
had a confidence about the game playing
going in that you could slow that
offense down you hold them the three
points define what was the biggest thing
that you guys want to do defensively in
order to stop the Rams
no I think we prepare well and we
practice well then you know the culture
came up with a great game plan and we
executed it as best as we can you know
it wasn't just one person and it was the
whole team the d-line stopping the run
you know getting pressure on the
quarterback the secondary plan tight
coverage on the back end so it all went
hand in hand but 424 remaining in the
fourth quarter the Rams are driving
they're trying to tie this thing up at
10 to 10 and yet you made the biggest
play I think the biggest play of Super
Bowl 53 your interception of Jared golf
tell me what you saw on that play and
then kind of to me what happened after
you why didn't you get up and try to
make a play go for a touchdown to be
honest you know we had a blitz call and
you know then a little boy had to come
out fast I kind of saw him looking at
him the whole time I thought a bobble
for you know the receiver could see it
so I was able to talk about quicker than
him and you know they got a lot of
pressure on the quarterback and I just
went up and made a great a great play
and you know I didn't want to you know
do nothing crazy I want to be catching
it and get down and you know put the
ball on offense enhance five tackles
interception forced fumble pass is
deflected you did pretty much everything
in that Super Bowl and I remember after
the game the the kind of mutual respect
that I wish people get a chance to see
was that Brandon cooks was your teammate
a year ago and I know you guys had a lot
of battles at practice but what was said
between you two after the game because
you guys weren't at it and he kind of
kept him in check but there was a mutual
respect between both you guys what was
said after the game oh man you know he's
very emotional you know me and Brandon
you know we came in together
last year New England it was a best
friend you know every since you know he
and just seeing him having a great year
and me going against him in the Super
Bowl you know he's a tough guy to cover
and after the game I just told him that
I loved him you know it was a great
battle and he made it hard on me and you
know it was just emotional moment
and you know I just caught it my lover
let me keep your head up and you know
it's beyond football for me and we best
friends and and I love them and I put
them on I get up with them at all Super
Bowl champion for the New England
Patriots to find Gilmour joining the
Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison filling in
for rich and look you had a chance to
join well Jason McCord II had a chance
to join that defensive secondary for the
Patriots I the play in which I thought
that honestly saved the game was Jason
coming from his third on the one side of
the field kind of a coverage breakdown
on the other side chasing down and
knocking the ball out of Brandon cooks
his hands well what did you see on that
play and what did you guys talk about on
a silent after he broke up that big huge
what could have been a huge play for the
Rams I was a great play by him he nobody
talked about it earlier in a in the game
they kind of ran the same play but they
didn't throw it and you know he was
ready that's that's why you go to the
sideline study in and you know sometimes
teams go back to the same thing so you
know you made a great play for us and
you know that's what it takes to win a
game you know one of the things that
when you are now Super Bowl champion
you're the first team All Defense
all-pro in the NFL where do you feel you
stack up now in terms of corner backs in
the league do you finally feel like
you've gotten the recognition that you
deserve as the top cornerback in the
National Football League I feel like I
am but I don't like to say that I just
like other people to you know say it but
I believe in myself and my abilities to
help the team as best as I can any way I
can so I'm not really uh you know talk
about myself god with you know I just
try to let my game do the talking and
and do it that way didn't do it the
opposite way well you don't have to say
cuz I'll say it for you he's the best
burner back in the national football
league he's tough on Gilmore and look
last question before I let you go Steph
I'm trying to put together a movement or
like a holiday so what do you think
about this define April 16th okay
the day after tax day but April 16th
Bill Belichick's birthday
okay can we come up with a holiday
called the national hoodie day where
everyone wears cutoff hoodies around the
world to be inspired by Bill Belichick
what do you say about that
yeah it's a great idea all right I got
to let you go on this one so what do you
do now you're a Super Bowl champion
you're heading to the off-season now
what's next for us to find gilmore how
do you come back and do it again how
does this team do it again so just enjoy
I'm just enjoying this you know this
lamb right now and you know spend time
with the family you know relax a little
bit was a long season so you know and
still work out you know and steak
Stacey it and stay right but you know
this that times come it comes and you
get your mind ready your body ready for
that for that time just right now I'm
just enjoying my time off and taking
care of my body and doing as much as I
can to get back i Steph I appreciate the
time as always but you're still my
rookie so just gonna let you know that
he's still my rookie all right all right
I appreciate it best of luck as always
man and congratulations he's defined
Gilmore Super Bowl 53 champion of the
New England Patriots the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience